حياكم الله بدات بوادره تقارب التركيه مع
دمشق تظهر بعد يوم من اول لقاء جمع وزراء
دفاع سوريا وتركيا وروسيا في موسكو منذ 11
عاما تركيا قدمت ما يعتبره البعض تنازلات
للنظام الاسد او كما وصفها اخرون هدايا
على حساب الاكراد كما مهدت الطريقه
للقاءات وشيكا وابرام اتفاقيه وزير
الخارجيه التركيه مولود شاوي شوبلو اكد
استعداد انقره لنقل السيطره بمناطق وجودها
في سوريا الى دمشق في حال تحقيق الاستقرار
السياسي وهنا طبعا نتحدث عن مناطق الشمال
السوري قال مولود اشوي شغلوا ان تركيا
ترغب بعوده اللاجئين السوريين وتعمل على
تامين ذلك واشار الى ان هذه الملفات ستطرح
في لقاء غريب سيجمعه مع نظيره السوري فيصل
المقداد
الى تطبيق القرار الاممي
2154 بشان الحالي في سوريا
[موسيقى]
عن اول تعليقنا كرديين سوريين على
التطورات بين انقره ونظام الاسد برعايه
الروسيه اعتبرت الاداره الذاتيه الكرديه
في شمال شرق سوريا ان اللقاء يهدف
لترسيليا اقدام الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان وحزبه في السلطه قبل الانتخابات
التركيه القادمه وان هذه اللقاء ستتطور
للمرحله الجديده من الصفقات والخطه
المعاديه لمصالح السوريين والسعيد ليحيى
اتفاقيه اضنه التي كانت مضحكه وجائره بحق
الشعوب المنطقه كما طلبت الاداره كل من
روسيا والنظام السوري بالكشف عن فحوى هذه
اللقاءات الامنيه والعسكريه بعد 12 عاما
من العداء والاحتلال والتدمير في سوريا
التي تعيش اوضاعا ماساويه